قفزت بالشركات الامنيه مجددا الى واجهه
الاحداث العالميه مطرح تساؤلات حول الدور
الذي تلعبه هذه الشركات وما اذا كنا نتجه
نحو خصخصه الحروب الشركات الامنيه
والعسكريه وان ظهرت لاول مره بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه الى ان جذورها قديمه
مرتبطه بعصابات المرتزقه التي يدفع لها
المال مقابل القيام بعمليات عسكريه لكن
صفه الارتزاق ذات المدلول البشع يتم اليوم
اعاده تجميلها نحتا وتحت مسميات جديده ذات
طبيعه تجاريه مقابل خدمه امنيه او عسكريه
وما زال الجدل قائما بشان قانونيتها اول
ظهور لشركه امنيه في العالم كان بالولايات
المتحده في عام
1946 اسسها محاربون قدامه واطلقوا عليها
اسماء داينكورب غير ان شهره الشركات
الامنيه برزت بعد احتلال العراق في عام
2003 ودوره في حمايه شخصيات ومنشات مدنيه
وعسكريه مقابل عقود بالمليارات دفعتها
الاداره الامريكيه حينها لهذه الشركات على
غرار بلاك ووتر الا ان سمعه بلاك ووتر
تشوهت بعد ارتكابها لمجازر وتجاوزات في حق
مدنيين عزل على غرار مجزره النسور في
بغداد في عام 2007
[موسيقى]
اهم الاسباب التي تلجا فيها بعض الدول الى
الشركات الامنيه والعسكريه انها لا تحتكم
لضوابط القانون الدولي وبالتالي يمكن
التبرا منها في حال تورطت في جرائم حرب
عندما قصف الجيش الامريكي عناصر فاجنر في
سوريا قتل العشرات منهم تبرات روسيا منهم
والا كانت ستجبر على الرد ومواجهه
الولايات المتحده كما ان الشركات الامنيه
والعسكريه يقودها عاده ضباط محترفون خارج
الخدمه يتميزون بكفاءه عاليه في اداء
المهام الموكله لهم ومتحررون من القيود
البيروقراطيه التي تميز الجيوش النظاميه
من الانتقادات التي توجه الى الشركات
الامنيه ان عناصرها يتبعون صاحب الشركه
وليس الدوله ولا يحكمهم قانون عسكري ولا
تدرج في الرتب ما يجعل السيطره عليهم امرا
ليس سهلا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات